[Music]
you say hello to everybody hi beautiful
family you know my friend Sean Gunn so
is it a bit like that I mean you guys
are so tight we talked a little bit
about this before but does it feel a bit
like a family reunion not only coming
back for this movie but also here
tonight yes I this is the first time
that a premiere I feel excited but I'm
not nervous like I'm not anxious I so
many things go through your mind like
don't fall please don't have any
lipstick on your teeth like here go
ahead check it and and also like I hope
my friends like my colleagues felt that
I did a good job and in this this film I
just I feel so supported you know and I
and I and I support my friends are
amazing and I gotta said you are
outnumbered at home these days I mean
how much fun you know what I'm used to
it i've done all these action movies
that I'm usually like outnumbered you
know so I'm the boys are so true boat
know and you know what ones they grow up
and they become dudes I'm gonna rub it
in their face I'm gonna be so girly I'm
gonna be so girly they're gonna be like
annoyed by their mom every single day or
you can order you could have girl I had
three kids I'm just sure how am I gonna
know no we're heal enough three's a nap
[Music]
you